Um, This is pretty amazing.
CUSTOMER: So this is
a rare find, then?
Well, that's if it's real.
CUSTOMER: 400?
I'm looking online, this
thing is worth $1,000!
Were you able to sell
into your computer?
RICK (VOICEOVER): A guy brought
in an extremely rare 1861 Half
Eagle.
That is if it's one of the
few minted in North Carolina.
So I called in my coin guy,
Mike, to take a closer look.
Just to make sure it's
not a counterfeit.
MIKE: What's up, Rick?
RICK: 1861 Charlotte.
MIKE: That's a rare one.
1861 Philadelphia, there
was over 700,000 of those.
We're talking five,
six hundred bucks.
With a "C," we're
talking a whole lot more.
20 times as much.
CUSTOMER: That's good news.
That's great news.
MIKE: Yes, yes, absolutely.
CUSTOMER: So this is
a rare find, then?
Well, that's if it's real.
I'd like to take a look
at the mint mark and--
Oh, a-- absolutely.
OK.
RICK: How's it look?
After looking at it, yes,
I believe that it is a, uh,
authentic Charlotte minted coin.
That's awesome, awesome news.
COREY: So, what's it worth?
You could get about 15,000--
Wow.
--for this coin.
All right, beat it Mike.
MIKE: (LAUGHS) Hey,
nice to meet you.
CUSTOMER: No, hey thank you.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Good luck, guys.
What do-- What
do you want to do?
$7,500.
Mm, no.
12.
I think you'll do just fine.
RICK: I still have
to send this off.
Things can pop up
when I send it off.
I end up assuming all the risk.
Let's somewhat
split the difference.
How about 95?
I'll go eight grand,
not a penny more.
I'm good.
Eight grand.
- All right.
Good doing business.
COREY: Come on man,
I'll write you up
You got it.
All right, thank you.
CUSTOMER: How are you?
RICK: Pretty good.
I have a coin from
the Byzantine Empire
I'd like to sell.
RICK: Um, this is
pretty amazing.
Where in the world
did you get this?
CUSTOMER: I actually
bought a group of books
from an antique store a while
back, and in one of them,
that was actually
inside the spine.
How much do you want for it?
CUSTOMER: I was
thinking about $1,900.
I'll give you like
800 bucks for it.
Nah, that-- that's
a little bit too low.
I mean, th-- that's
a thousand years old.
Can you do like, 16?
RICK: I'll go $1,100.
11?
Yeah, I guess we can do 11.
OK, $1,100.
All right, I'll meet
you right over there.
RICK (VOICEOVER): My go-to
guy for ancient coins, Dave,
is here to give me
a grade and a price.
Hey man.
How you been?
RICK: Good.
Here's the coin.
Ah, it's fantastic.
This is a coin of the Byzantine
Emperor Constantine IX.
He's on the reverse,
and Jesus Christ
is on the obverse, the front.
So is it the real deal, or?
DAVE: Looks good.
RICK: Big question.
What's it worth?
DAVE: These are not
always worth what
people might think they are.
OK.
I see these going
typically, in the marketplace
today, for between 700 and
$1,000 in this condition.
RICK: That's it?
DAVE: It should be
worth thousands.
And I think you just ran into
a market that, at present, is
terribly undervalued.
RICK: All right.
Not the news I was
exactly looking for.
Lesson learned, I'll call
you next time. (LAUGHS)
Yeah, call me first.
All right, thanks man.
Thank you.
COREY: What you got?
It's an 1874 chop
marked trade dollar.
COREY: So, where'd
you get this at, man?
Actually, I got it
at a coin trade show
in California a few years
back, up in San Francisco.
OK.
The whole reason these
things came about
is because China, and a bunch
of other countries in Asia,
they didn't like our
currency when we would go
over there and trade with them.
But believe it or
not they actually
liked the Mexican
peso more because it
had more silver in it.
We started making these, we
put a little bit more silver
in them so they
would actually prefer
these over the Mexican peso.
They would take them and
they would take a little tool
and they'd put a
chop mark in it.
And that's how they kind of
tested the silver in them.
They were never meant to
get into the hands of normal
consumers in the United States.
But what ended up
happening is, you know,
silver prices started
to really fall
so China threw all their old
trade dollars on some ships
and brought them into
the United States
and traded them for gold.
CUSTOMER: OK.
So what do you want
to do with it, man?
It's time to sell it.
All right, uh, I'd be willing
to give you around $400 for it.
400?
I'm looking online, this
thing's worth $1,000!
Were you able to sell
it to your computer?
CUSTOMER: I mean, can
you come up a little bit?
Like, at least 800.
COREY: I'll go like 450, man.
750.
The problem is, is
that it's chop marked.
There's a big debate on whether
or not a chop mark is just
part of the coin's
history, or if it's
just damage that was done to the
coin by the Chinese government.
Uh, that being said, the most
I'm gonna go is $500, dude.
Well, $500?
500.
Come with me,
we'll write you up.